- Welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning.
You know that this is the
place where I want to help you
to become successful in the
first years of your career.
And today's topic is a fan favorite.
It's a topic that many of
you have already requested
and this is the famous
dreaded consulting bag.
How do you pack your bag as a consultant?
This is what we're going to discuss today.
I will show you how I packed my bag
as a consultant in the past.
And I will share some tricks
which are my perspective,
what you will likely need,
what you probably won't need
and probably what can be a life
saver in certain situations.
So before we dive into it,
let me start by providing
some context. So as
you know if you've seen
some other videos on my
channel, the typical work week
in the life of a consultant is that
from Monday to Thursday
you're at the client.
So usually Monday morning,
you take the first flight
in the morning, to fly out,
fly to the client then you
fly back Thursday evening.
And this, for this reason,
requires you of course
to have a well packed bag
to live through the week.
Of course, at the moment,
due to the current health situation,
the rhythm looks a bit different.
Travel is down, people are
not traveling that much.
There's more home office.
They also know that travel is already
starting to pick up again slowly.
So trust that this will
become more relevant
for you in the future again.
So let's start by talking
about the exterior
because there are some little things
that you can do as well.
And one of the main problems
that you will face is,
that many, many consultants
will use very similar bags..
So at the airport, there were lots of bags
that pretty much looked the same.
So my tip is , use something like this,
a little piece of something
just to mark your bag
that everybody knows that this is yours.
And that you can quickly distinguish it
from other bags as well.
And of course a proper luggage
tag with the information,
with your personal details will be helpful
So that in case you lose
it, in case somebody else
finds this, they know who you are
and how they can reach you.
So why do consultants
even care so much what
exactly they pack into their bag?
And the main reason is,
that you will not check your luggage,
so you can only bring hand luggage.
and the reason is that it
would just take too much time
if after you land, you go
to the luggage bed conveyor.
You wait for your piece
of baggage to pick it up.
The team wants to directly take the taxi,
take the cab to the client once you land.
So everybody would just
pick up hand luggage.
There will be no checked in luggage.
So let's start how these
bags are structured.
And of course the
different types of luggages
will be different.
But usually it'll have
one compartment where
it's more free float, right?
And one compartment that
you have a fixed thing
that you can make over it to
really keep it all in place.
And I like to have the things
which are a bit more
delicate like the shirts
where you don't wanna
have too many wrinkles
after you iron them to have
them rather in this part,
because this is then how
you keep it all together
how you make sure that it's all in it.
So let's start indeed with the shirts.
And here what you need to understand
is that on Monday morning,
you will already drive to the client
and then fly to the client fully dressed.
So in your suit, in your shirt and so on.
So from Monday, you
already wear your outfit.
This means that you still need outfits
for Tuesday, Wednesday,
and Thursday, so three days
but then it's a good
best practice to always
have an additional one in store with you.
So that for instance,
if for whatever reason,
you might need to stay there
for another day spontaneously,
that you would be able to stay there
for instance on Friday as well,
without running out of cloth.
So it's best practice to really
have four clothes with you.
Four pieces of shirts, and of
course here types of shirts
you see here, so I might make
another video in the future
talking a bit more about the
stupid consultant outfit.
What types of shorts,
what types of suits
you're supposed to wear,
but like usual plain colors,
white, blue, some simple stripes.
This is what's usually, okay
this is what you were
wearing most of the time.
So let's start with them indeed.
And of course here, the critical
thing is how you fold them
because you wanna make
sure that they're not
too wrinkled when you then
unpack them in the hotel.
So simple way of doing
it after you iron is
do it like this, put
these arms here together
and then fold it once like
this to have such a package.
Then I take this package
and try to fit this into this half here.
And you know, you might do some
delicate additional folding.
Just of course, the less folding
you do the better for this
in order to fit this in properly.
The next item to take
care of is your underwear
And here for the same logic,
you already wear your things on Monday.
They don't need four more days
to be covered until Friday.
And then my recommendation
is to bring even
one additional one in case
you want to do some sports.
So for instance, one pair of sports socks
this always makes sense.
So you have five additional
pieces of underwear.
Now, if you look here in the compartment
where we put the shirts,
here it makes sense
to then staff this a little
bit here in the free spaces,
because this will then have
this whole area not to move so much.
And the less, it all
moves, the less wrinkles,
the less problems you get
with ironing your shirts afterwards.
So once you've all put it in,
then you can close this
and this then should make sure
that this is more or less firmly secured.
And then this first half
part of the bag is done.
Once you then unpack
your bag in the hotel,
it always makes sense to check
how wrinkly your shirts really are.
And indeed most business
hotels will have opportunity
to helping them with the
ironing or to provide you
the facilities so that you
can then iron the shirts
in the perfect way
if they are too wrinkly
for you to wear them.
Next point is the shoes.
And this is always a question
of personal philosophy
because indeed in such a bag
you usually only have place
for one additional pair of shoes.
So you really already wear
your business shoes on Monday.
So the question is what is the
second pair that you bring?
And some colleagues like to bring
a second pair of business shoes
so that then they can alternate
the shoes during the week.
This of course can make a lot of sense
and will help you to really keep the shoes
in a well looking place for the long term.
Personally I always liked
to prioritize sports.
So I always brought a
pair of running shoes
so that I have these with me.
And this is then indeed something
that you can just then
pack in the second half.
They usually did it in some way like this
to have the shoes in here in the section.
I often frankly also use
the shoe bag to make sure
that then the potentially dirty shoes
are not making other
things dirty here as well.
So for the sake of simplicity,
I'm not having these here
but indeed, you could pack
these actually in a simple
garbage bag, a simple plastic
garbage bag, for instance,
to have this clean and secured here.
Next is a leisure outfit.
This is a little bit optional.
Not all colleagues do this,
but sometimes it can be nice.
And this is for some
evenings with your colleagues
or maybe it's nice to go to
the hotel first to change
to then not keep continuing
wearing your dress
shirt that you wear all day from work.
But here indeed, most
colleagues, will do this anyway
so it's not absolutely required
but sometimes it's nice
just to have a normal pair
of trousers and just a normal
polo shirt or something
like this that you can, wear
and do not need to walk around
with your business outfit all the time.
So this is something that
you can just put in here
to make this work for you.
The next one is your sports outfit.
So we already have the shoes
and the running socks in the bag.
Now, of course, a pair
of running trousers and then a
running short will be helpful
and appreciated depending
on the spot that you do,
you of course might also
be taking other materials
that you need to make this work for you.
Next one is something
to keep you a bit warm
And here most people either
have an additional jumper
that they take with them, or
maybe also a vest like this.
So often there's not
enough space to take both.
Personally. I'd like to
have something like this.
It's a vest.
This is always nice.
And you can also wear it
in the team room under
your suit, for instance.
So this is always a nice addition
that's often worthwhile just
to pack and to have with you
when you pack your back.
Next one is ties.
So these days you do not need
to wear a tie at every client,
but there are still some clients
that we require you to wear
around where this is just
part of the dress code.
You'll just got to have
selection of basic colors
nothing too crazy, like
dark blue, red green.
These are colors that I
personally like to wear.
And here indeed, if you know
that you will need a tie,
then pack enough, make
sure that you have three
or four that you can really
alternate during the week.
But even if you had a client
where you do not expect
that you need to wear a tie where you know
that you actually don't need to do that.
It's always good practice to
have at least one tie with you.
So if in case maybe you are
suddenly meeting somebody else,
as a senior person, maybe also
outside of the organization
on a short notice, need
to join another workshop.
Another pitch, maybe
even have another client
that you are flexible, that
you have a tie with you
that you can wear.
This is then required for
the setting that you're in.
And here often it's good
just to roll it a bit
make sure that you don't need it to hurt,
but a simple roll like this is
fine where then I can put it
in the bag and make this
work in a proper way.
And last but not least your toilet bag
with all the sanitary things that you need
during your stay in the hotel.
So here, the good thing is
if you're missing something
you forgot something at home,
most of these business hotels
will be able to provide you
with all the basic
things like a toothpaste
for instance, but it's
of course always nicer to
have your own things
that you can then bring.
So indeed, I would just
always also pack it here
to the side and make sure that
it doesn't interfere
too much with your ties.
And then these days, of course,
some additional corona masks.
It's always helpful to
have these in the bag
as well to then have it
here when you need it.
So these are all the essentials indeed.
After you have all this,
you can pick it up,
make sure it all fits well.
And you see this nicely fits
out, such a hand luggage.
This is now also a small size these days.
They're even a bit larger sizes
of hand luggage that are
allowed to be brought
into the cabin of the airplane.
So this is fine to see that
you can easily close this.
So that's it, and from my experience,
this is the setup that works really well.
This is how I did it most of the time.
Some colleagues like
to bring a second suit.
And here the rationale is,
well if you only have one suit with you
that you are wearing on Monday, of course,
you're risking it there,
maybe you spill some coffee over it.
Maybe your trousers have some problem.
That's maybe a damage
maybe they'll rip apart.
And then of course you
have quite some problems.
If then you have nothing
else to wear anymore.
This is now one of the
reasons why some people like
to bring a second suit.
And then ,of course,
you can bring a simple suit bag like this,
this works that you can
then often put it together.
You can then carry it.
And then you can also have
it here around the bag.
If you then travel around
the airport, this can work.
And if you have this,
the additional benefit
of using this is that if you then open it,
you can use this also
as a place just to have
some other things by opening
it and just putting more stuff
here in the bottom.
So this can then just
use for additional space.
So personally, I did not do this.
I did not take this with
me most of the time.
I rather preferred a leaner setup.
And indeed for these cases where
maybe really you spill
tea on your trousers,
or anything like this, I just like to
take a rather one pair
of trousers from pair
of leisure trousers, like
the one that I'm currently
wearing right now, because
this is a trial that
in the worst case, you might
also be able just to bring
to the client, wear with a dress shirt
and then maybe you're not wearing a suit,
but it will still look proper
and will give you this one additional day
that it might need you
to just pick up another
dress trial that summarates .
So that was my routine, how
I did it most of the time
but I'll also wanna stress that
there's nothing like the golden rule book
of how you need to pack
your bag as a consultant.
And if you ask different people ,
they will come up with
different suggestions,
different styles different
things that are important to them
what to bring with them.
So here I'd also love to hear your views
your opinions as well.
Leave me a comment in the comment section
below the video to let
me know what your tips
and tricks were, what the things were
that you did into your bag.
And I will do my very best to answer
every single comment that you write.
So as always, if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe
to the channel to stay up
to date on all my content.
I also have an Instagram
where you can see even
more content from me.
My handle is Firm Learning there.
And if you want to know
even more about consulting,
I have one signature
course about slide writing
abut how to create presentations
in the style of leading consulting firms.
If you're interested in that
I have over 10,000 students
who took the course already.
There's a link to the course
in the video description.
Check it out.
And now, I also wanna say a big thank you
to all the members of Firm Learning.
You're really making a big
contribution to the channel.
Thanks so much for your support.
And if you wanna become a member as well
hit the join button next
to the subscribe button
to check it all out.
My name is Heinrich.
I release new videos every
single Saturday on my channel.
So talk to you again
next week, next Saturday.
until then, good weekend to all of you.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Bye bye.